I'm Chris Nowinski and odds are if
you've met me in the last five years
I've asked you after a few minutes a bit
of an odd question can I have your brain
now it only seems like a strange
question if you don't know my story so
please let me share it with you
I had grew up outside Chicago and I was
an athlete and I was very lucky to get
recruited to play football at Harvard
University so that's me
and then after graduating like like most
Harvard graduates I decided I wanted to
join the WWE so that's also made sure
you remember me from Monday Night Raw in
2002 and 2003 and I had a blast playing
what people effectually like to call
Chris Harvard the Ivy League snob it was
perfect for me but unfortunately I got
kicked in the head by my colleague Bubba
ray Dudley and I suffered a severe
concussion and it led to what became
permanent post concussion symptoms
constant headaches inability to sleep
depression feeling in a fog and in that
first year I tried to figure out how
could I make this pain go away and I
wasn't getting the answers I need from
doctors and so I started digging into
the medical literature and I found
there's this whole story about
concussions that we weren't really being
told and so I decided to write a book
about it called head games footballs
concussion crisis that came out 2006 but
in that process I learned it's not
really just about concussions I learned
about a disease called chronic traumatic
encephalopathy or CTE what we used to
call punch-drunk because we only knew
about it from boxers we knew that
getting hit in the head too many times
with boxers would cause their brain to
essentially start to rot to degenerate
and they'd have symptoms like memory
problems and problems with cognition
depression impulse control issues
aggression so I wrote about I basically
I got I got injured at the right time in
which the first two NFL players
were studied for this disease and it
turned out they both had it the first
was Mike Webster 50 years old already
had dementia the second Terry long 45
years old when he took his life the
medical examiner in Pittsburgh decided
to look at their brains and found this
disease I wrote a chapter about it and I
thought people would make a big deal out
of it but shockingly even when the first
two cases came in positive there was
never a national news story about this
what's going on in football with these
cases of CTE so the book comes out not a
whole Lots happening and one day I read
the newspaper November 20th 2006 I find
out that Andre waters just took his life
those are you know football Andre waters
was someone I grew up watching former
Philadelphia Eagles strong saftey 46
years old a division 2 football coach
when he decided to put a gun to his head
in the article they reminded me his
nickname was dirty waters he was known
for leading with his head so I thought
you know what I'm just gonna look up did
he ever talk about the concussions he
had and I found a quote from 1994 where
Andre waters said I stopped counting my
concussions at 15 I wouldn't say
anything I just sniffs smelling salts
and go back out there and I thought I
wonder if he might have CTE too if that
might have contributed to whatever him
choose to end his life so I end up
calling the doctor who did the first two
studies and I said hey I think you
should study Andre waters and he said
I'd be happy to the problem is the first
two cases died in the county in which I
work and I could study them as part of
my job I can't do that with Andre waters
he died in Florida if you want me to
study him you're gonna have to figure
out how to get me the brain so I said
okay how does one get a brain
so I racked my brain and I thought well
why don't I call the medical examiner
who I think has the brain right now so I
called up the medical examiner in
Florida and I said hey you don't know me
but you still have the brain of Andre
waters and he said yes I do and I said
okay are you gonna study him for CTE and
he said no in fact he at that time he
didn't believe that that was a real
disease I said okay if you're not do you
mind if I get if I have it and he said
well young man you I can't give you the
brain you need his family's permission
but if you do get his the permission of
his next of kin
I will release the brain to you and I
said great and then I realized I had to
figure out who's next of kin wasn't
asked them and it turned out it was
Andre waters 88 year old mother and I
sat there and I took a breath and I
thought am I really gonna cold call an
88 year old grieving mother who just
lost her son to suicide and almost
everything in me said don't do it it's
it's too much to put this poor woman
through she's been through so much
already
but then this other voice in my head
said you know what if guys are killing
themselves from this disease and we
could study it to maybe prevent this
happening the future sometimes you just
got to suck it up and do something
that's very hard so I called her first
time nobody answered
second time no one answered there no
voicemails the fifth time I got an
answer and thank God that Andre waters
family was so gracious about the call
and said you know what we want to know
what happened Andre we want to know why
he changed so much in the last five
years of his life and so we studied the
brain and turned out that he did have
CTE he became the third NFL player
diagnosed with the disease this is what
it looks like he was somewhere between
mild and severe okay we have three of
three NFL players here maybe this needs
to get a little bit more serious maybe
something's happening here so I ended up
starting the concussion Legacy
Foundation actually formalize the work
so
just some guy calling for brains and I
searched the world and I put together
the best research team I could find so
he partnered with Boston University we
partnered with scientists at the VA here
in Boston and we started a brain bank
turns out if you want to know how to
cure degenerative brain disease you have
to start by actually studying the brains
at this point we were the first Center
in the world focused on CTE just had not
been studied formally and so we start
this brain bank and it's my job to get
the brains for dr. Ann McKie and her
brain bank right in the middle we also
work at dr. Bob Stern dr. Robert Cantu
it's really my dream team of scientists
that I support
so my jobs to get the brains and I was
very successful in those early years
since 2007 I've started every day by
reading the obituaries and it's a tough
way to live and it's hard on me and it's
even worse on these poor families that
I've been calling for the last ten years
to ask for their brains and so early on
in the processes that started that
really eat away at me I said you know
what can I find another way to get
people to donate their brains to this
research and I figured out you know what
if we made couldn't create a culture of
brain donation in this country what if
it became normal for athletes to donate
their brain after they died and so I
started was a brain donation registry
and I started asking athletes if they
would publicly pledged to donate their
brain to science and it started with
actually a hockey player in 2009 one of
my first pledges was a former Harvard
hockey player no well she was in the NHL
at the time it was a slow start people
understanding what this was about so
when the news hit the front page Nowell
pledging his brain the science said he
went in the locker room the next day one
of his teammates pulled him aside said
hey I heard you're donating your brain
to science and he said yep and he said
wow how many games are gonna miss true
story
right but we've been remarkably
successful over 2500 athletes have
signed up they get a brain donation card
they keep in their wallet this is mine I
was obviously first it says here one and
I will donate my brain to this web we've
all spent lucky to have people like
Brandi Chastain the women's soccer icon
NASCAR's Dale Earnhardt jr. just two
weeks ago hall-of-famer Nick Buoniconti
drew being diagnosed with dementia
signed up to pledge his brain so it's
been wonderful and the great thing about
it that it has worked in changing how
we're able to get brains so now instead
of me having to call anymore families
call us and our phones ring off the hook
and so I can now focus on taking this
information figure out how do we work
towards a cure how do we work towards
prevention and so my life has gotten a
lot easier this is just some of the
headlines that we've been able to get
over the years from athletes pledging
their brain the problem has been what we
learned so when we started this only 45
cases existed in the world of this
disease that have been studied in brain
banks since then we have acquired 500
brains and found over 300 of them have
CTE to put that in perspective the rest
of the world has not studied a hundred
brains since we started this what we've
seen though is very frightening so some
of you might have seen the headline in
July in the New York Times in a recent
study we published that of the first
hundred and eleven NFL players we looked
at 110 were positive for this disease of
the first 53 college football players we
looked at 48 had this disease that's
something that's a very big concern to
me and so now I'm very much focused on
what can we do to actually treat this
disease we don't we still can't diagnose
CTE living people
we have no treatments that are going to
be coming out of the pharmaceutical
industry in the next five years this is
a long long fight but our concussion
legacy foundation is here to not only
facilitate this work and that's the long
game but the short game is hey we
can prevent this we can prevent this
disease if we just stopped hitting
people in the head so much and frankly
we need to stop hitting children in the
head
turns out it's not a great idea to hit a
five-year-old and had 500 times each
year and it does actually open up the
door to this disease and so we got a lot
of work ahead of us but I have great
hope that we're on our way to curing
this disease but I hope you understand
my story a little more now and now that
we've gotten to know each other a little
bit better this is the time where I ask
you can I have your brain thank you very
much
[Applause]